Hello everyone, welcome back to the capablanca saga
We are back at the 1914 Tournament of Sun picture book and the Capablanca faces a very strong Hungarian chess master
Isadora Ginsberg and
Ginsberg had a very very long Chester year behind him at the moment here in 1914
he's 60 years old and
He started his just career actually
Pretending to be a chess automaton the so called Mephisto
It's similar to the Turk. I don't know if all of you know, what the Turk was the the so-called
Mechanical automaton that played chess even though you know
It was a hoax there was actually a person hiding inside it here
You can see that this is a reconstructed Turk from the 1980s as the real Turk was
ruined in a fire in 1954
and sorry in 1854 and
After that, you know, it would just burn down and this is basically what it looked like to my knowledge there
You see the place where you fit a person inside and from there through some mechanical sorcery
Now you would move the pieces and then the Turk would beat you and you know
They've been fooling people with the Turk for over 80 years
They defeated some very famous people like Napoleon Bonaparte a Benjamin Franklin and so on
but is there Ginsberg and when he was 20 years old he started controlling the Mephisto, but it was a different type of
Automaton it was a controlled
Electronically and also remotely so there was there wasn't a person hiding inside of it
it was just a table with a chest and the Mephisto it was a
Red Devil attached to the table that moved the pieces
So I've never actually seen it work as the whereabouts of the Mephisto are unknown hour later Mephisto became a well-known
Chess chess playing automaton that that you can buy even today
But yeah, and also interestingly in the the Turk was burned down in
1854 and also Isadora Ginsberg was born in 1854. So is there a coincidence, you know hard to say?
And yeah, a very strong player Capablanca approaching his prime win already, you know
way past his prime Greene's works almost 25 years before the 1914 tournament of some pitcher Pedro Berg in
1891 so 23 years ago
faced Williams Chinese for the title of roaches championship and he played an excellent match the the
the match was first the first eight wins or
20 games and then who has the better score the game ended six to four in favor of Chinese after 18 games as
There was no more chance for Ginsburg to actually win the match. So Stannis was awarded the title and declared champion
but a very strong player and here like I said
Kabul uncle some 26 years old Ginsberg
60 years old. It's going to be quite a game. So I do hope you're ready for it
Ginsberg has the white pieces and he opens with E for we have E 5 by Capablanca and now
Like I said Ginsberg is 60 years old here and he did not just show up here to be seen he's here to fight
So F for the Kings gambit and as you all know capablanca
It refutes every gambit and most easily by accepting it
so e captures on f4 and a bunch of the c4 the so called bishops gambit to the Kings gambit and
Trying to get black to go for this Queen to h4 check which seems very appealing
But of course you will not play g3 King get 1 and then white will play d4
Then gum comes Knight to f3 white will use this weird position of the black Queen to develop the pieces
It was not considered good for black. So after Bishop to c4 cover Blanca continues developing Knight to f6 attacks d4 pawn Knight to c3
Ginsburg defends the pawn and now Bishop to b4 a principle idea attacking the defender of d4 pawn and here you don't really
Have the option of playing d3 to defend it because d5 will be very strong for black here
Why would have to give up the bishop pair and after Knight captures still your United?
Threatened it captures and now even Queen captures as possible
Attacking the g2 pawn where black would be better
So after this Bishop to b4 move
We have E 5 by news Berg and it seems like white is creating something white hair white is starting the initiative
But black is actually perfect we find here
Of course, you will not move the night even though there are no good squares for you to actually move the night
You can't go g4. H5. The Queen is covering those squares then I discovering these squares you could go back, but that's pretty much pointless
d5 by capablanca
and now this exchange will not favour why for example
Captures captures and now you could go up. We need to check black block
you'll capture here attack the rook rook g8 and
It seems like white achieved something but not really black is a much ahead in development black can just develop the knight develop the Queen
Castle queenside
G7 pawn will be captured and then black will have a nice semi open G file for the rook
Well white still has a king in the middle of the board and still has to figure out how to go about this
So after d5 with Bishop to b3 Bishop e5 check also an option against Burgos for Bishop to b3
And now comes Knight to e4 and of course you cannot capture here
If you capture the pawn, then comes Queen to h4, check and black wins
the game g3 now comes pawn captures H captures and now well
Either you start running away and lose a lot of material or you just get checkmated. So after 94, we have Knight to f3
preventing Queen h4 check and now comes c6
and here Queen to e to here white prepares the
White brothers to eliminate the d4 Knight the Queen and Knight threatened to capture and the Capablanca wants to push g5
So for the moment, it's not possible first. He captures in c3
Bishop captures on c3 now the the strong knight is stronger than the bishop. We have d captors on c3 opening up blacks
wise dark square bishop and now g5 by Capablanca
We have nice the d2 wanting to get rid of this night and now push up to f5
Knight captures with Bishop captures and here Bishop to b2 now Ginsburg also has the option of castling queenside
we have Knight to d7 going after d5 pawn and now C for
Attacking Capablanca strong center, but also making room on c3 for the dark square bishop
queenie 7
we have seek after Sundy 5c captures on d5 and Bishop to c3 and
Here it would be too soon to go after the pawn
If you play Knight captures
Then you just run into the spin white can go Queen b5 check now
You can go back with the night because you lose the rook on h8
So you'd have to move the king and it's where do you move the King?
if you go King f8
Then Bishop b4 wins the Queen and if you don't if you go something like King King go over to d8
Then you're just in the center of the board. White will Castle queenside and now your king is just in the line of
In the line of fire. So after Bishop to c3 we have castles by capablanca
first getting the King to safety and only now after
the castle link of a Blanca is ready to capture the pawn, but now
Ginsberg takes care of it east six attacks the night and also there's a discovered attack on the rook on h8
So to defend both threats
We have Knight to f6 and now comes a captures on f7 Queen captures and capablanca goes for Queen side castles
And now rook h2e. Sorry against bergen's Burgos for queenside castle and rook h2 e8
So as you can see
it's a Ginsburg who has the better prepare but capablanca is a bit a bit ahead in development and there are no
Useful discoveries for the moment a bunch of captures anything will just be met with Queen captures to whatever
Discovery was made and there there are no other useful discoveries, but rip f3 Queen can capture
so another problem Ginsburg goes for h4 with
H6h captures H captures, and now rook to h6 a very nice rock cliff to it that comes with a double attack
Towards the knight on f6. So kappa blanka defends that we look to e6
Defending the knights twice now, but also perhaps the night this roof can join
In the attack against the white king in some later point of the game
But we have Bishop captures rook captures on f6 and now not capturing immediately
But first Queen to g4 check we have looked to a5 blocking check
And also not allowing the roof to remain a target on f6 and here we have rook d2. H1
Doubling up on the H file here. This was a mistake by Ginsburg a rook to e1 was a better move
But I'll let you decide why it was a better move
Rook to e1 was supposed to be played against girl played rook to h1
and before this move still a playable position white is doing white is doing rate Capablanca did not
he's up upon but
Ginsburg is throwing a lot of pressure couple on Cosway here. Look to each one was played now
Feel free to pause the video here and try to figure out why this doesn't work and why rook to e1 would have been better
I will give you a couple of seconds as usual
For those of you who were able to do it. Congratulations, you are an excellent winner of games
And for those who who just won't enjoy the show rook h1 is a blunder
Because f3 here and now you can see that you cannot capture
If you captured and Bishop captures comes with an attack against the Queen and against the rook here, so it would not be possible
So if we return to this position before rooks to h1 was played rook to e1 is better
Now you're already
threatening rook captures only for the points pinned due to the bishop being on f3 and
Also now f3 doesn't really do anything
You can just capture it and the characters only comes with an attack against the Queen 24
There are no hidden dangers here, but ok. Look to each one of us played
Congratulations, if you found the refutation f3 pins were played
h7 rook - h7 attacking cover Blancas queen and now once again
I ask you to pause the video and try to find the end of this game
For those of you who were able to do it. Congratulations you are an excellent
Temporary sacrificer of Queens and for those who just want to show F. KERS on g2 was played a
Very temporary Queen sacrifice by Capablanca. And now if you capture on f7 you get 10 G captures on h1
You can bring a queen into the game
And now after you move the King or the Queen moves
You can just capture capture and in the end you will be up a whole rook
So after this F captures and g2 agains were played rook 1 to h6
And here kappa blanka just played
Pawn to g1 and he bring he brought up another queen into the game
Even though he could have brought a rock into the game, which check doesn't even doesn't really matter
It would still be winning for him. But Capablanca does not fool around when it's you know, when it's time to play chess, so
It was in this position and move 26 that Ginsburg resigned the game
Because after Queen captures just look at one wins the Queen and it's all captures captures
And now white is soon getting checkmate it if you go down here is rebuttal f3 check or queen to yun checkmate
So you'd have to go up the board king c 3 and then a 5 d 4 is coming the white king will be checkmated
fairly soon
Yeah after this
Move work up a Blanca brought another queen into the game
Isadora Ginsburg resigned the game and yet another victory for Jose Roca Blanco who is still the sole leader in this tournament
Next game we have the last game of the first part of the 1914 tournament in San Pittsburgh
So we're gonna have the standings after the first part before we go into the double round-robin where five players will just brawl it out
So yeah, that's the game. I do. Hope you enjoyed it and that you are enjoying my coverage of the Capablanca saga so far
I would like to thank Anton baklanov a Weasley Santos
Joseph compression in Karel Podolski, Anthony Villalpando for a contribution to my channel. Thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual. You can check to my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I will see you soon
Hopefully with some more interesting content Lia and stockfish are or I believe almost over would their match
So we're gonna perhaps visit that and next game. I believe it's horrible. Kappa blanka vs. The black death you
Joseph Henry Blackburn, so that should that should be a treat
Thank you all and I'll see you soon. Have an excellent rest of your Friday